everybody and welcome to the 4th Monte
Carlo within python tutorial video in
this video what we're going to be
working on is visualizing our our
betters and seeing more than just the
end result we actually want to see the
trajectory as well
so this will be especially useful when
we start comparing different better
types and assessing the volatility of
their strategy as well since this kind
of volatility and its grounds your
drawdown in a strategy often denotes
some form of risk or added risk the more
volatile the strategy is so at this
point even though we've got a better
some betters that just really they're
all using the same strategy we do know
that they end up at different points but
we haven't really seen how they got
there so for this we're going to
actually plot the full the full path and
you'll need matplotlib if you don't
already have it if you've watched many
of my tutorials you probably have
matplotlib if you don't to acquire it go
to matplotlib org and I don't know why
then I've downloaded like right up at
the top but for some reason they don't
and so scroll down a little bit ok and
here you can download the latest version
either get you've got Mac OS you've got
64 bit here and you've got your 32 bit
here so once you have matplotlib
downloaded you should be able to open up
a console type import matplotlib and it
should work if it doesn't work you
something went wrong so anyway luckily
it comes with a dot exe so just download
it and install it easy enough once
you've done that um you can begin with
the video all right so once you have
that go to the top and underneath import
random we're going to need a map lot
live of course and we're also going to
import matplotlib pipeline
as PLT next we need to generate the list
of plots that we're going to plot so
under simple better what we want to add
here is just under wager will just say
WX so we'll say wager and that's the X
variable and then we've got value and
that's the Y variable so that's how I'm
just going to denote them lowercase W
uppercase X lowercase V uppercase Y the
next thing I want to go ahead and do is
we're gonna actually be plotting the
current wager so since we're doing 100
wagers it just makes sense to make the
current wager one and then wager count
our while current wager is less than or
equal to wager counts so this will start
at 1 and end at 100 just so when we're
looking at things it just ends at 100
and makes sense to our eyeballs so once
we've done that the next thing that we
want to do is if let's see well under
both of these we need to do some work
here so we'll do W X dot append and so
again this was the wager count so we
just want to append current wager and
then W or I'm sorry the uppercase Y dot
append and this is where we append the
value it's a value so we do that after
we've rolled the dice and found out our
odds and then again down here we just do
the same thing or find out where we left
off so add those and then finally at the
end of all of this we just want to
instead of print funds we don't need to
do that anymore
instead what we're going to go ahead and
do is
PLT dot plot and what we want to plot is
double W X V Y ok so that's all we want
to do and then everything else runs the
same so while X is less so it's going to
do this and it's going to keep plotting
but we don't see the plot yet so the
next thing we want to do is go ahead and
actually plot this so we'll come down
here and we'll just say well add some
labels to it just for kicks plug Y label
so our Y label is what's
is account value and then imply X label
our X label is wager count and finally
we'll just run applause show okay so we
should be able to save this and what
this is going to do is basically with a
sample size of a hundred betters it's
going to run through with a simple
better strategy and it's going to plot
up each step of the way so the whole
trajectory for what we've got is a
starting amount of 10000 wager size of
100 and it's gonna is that right yeah
waiter size of 100 and it's going to do
10000 wagers let's just start it at a
smaller 100 wagers so we'll save that
and let's go ahead and run it and see if
we run into any problems nope we didn't
so here's our plot each line is a
different better and so as you can see
uh so far we have kind of a hard time
recognizing with our eyeballs that
there's any sort of house edge so with a
short number of wagers like a hundred we
don't really see those odds to like
black and white we do obviously see a
few of these betters lost some money but
no one went broke and some people made
money and all that so let's go ahead and
close this one and let's add a few more
wagers so let's say that we do a
thousand wagers and we'll run that one
and now we can see that there's
significantly more obviously wager uh
Messick's significantly more wagers but
the same number of actual people doing
the wager so we've got a hundred you
know people that are gambling here and
maybe now you can start to see that it's
got a little bit of a downward slope but
what if we increase this again and now
we're doing 10,000 wagers this one might
take it there we go
and now it's even more obvious what's
happening but again we have some people
here like this guy this blue guy that at
one point was even over $20,000 and it
looks like he ended at about $50,000 so
obviously you've got some successful
people but we can see after about the
4000 mark quite a few people
we went broke in this one um and then
all the way down here where we've got
people that lost way more money than
they even started with so that should
all have been fairly uh expected there
should be no surprises with this one
we'll even do let's see we can make it
uh let's get a thousand betters instead
and so if ten thousand will do a hundred
thousand I'll run this and I'll just
pause it while we run it let's see if
anybody made profit alright so here's
our example it took a little bit to come
up but anyway as you can see literally
no one made money at it with this
strategy so I think this brings the
point uh brings the point home that
literally without some sort of strategy
on a long enough timeline everyone loses
there wasn't a single person who
actually made a profit so if you're in
some sort of gambling scenario that has
an edge obviously you will lose overtime
there's no one that's lucky enough to
actually have made money here initially
some people did make money but
eventually whatever risk you're taking
on even if that's a 1% risk on a long
term scale it always catches up it just
always does so this is a good example of
that now again it shouldn't be too
surprising to you guys but also you
should be able to see here such a wide
range of outcome after you know a
hundred thousand so even though
everybody did lose there was still quite
the difference in how heavily some of
these people lost so that's going to
conclude this video in the next video
we're going to begin creating our new
better and this better is going to do
what a lot of people decide to do and
that is to double up on every loss so
say you're trading with a hundred
dollars each time you lose you just
double up so you're doing or you're
betting $100 if you lose now you bet 200
if you lose again now you bet 400 if you
win you go back to betting 100 and so on
uh so we're going to do that some people
believe that gives them some sort of
better odds or it's a way to kind of
scheme the system which again is
I have a bit of that gamblers fallacy
since people think the odds somehow get
higher you still only have 50/50 odds
but it is a form of a strategy so we
will indeed see how good that strategy
actually is so anyways hopefully that
sounds exciting to you guys stay tuned
the next video as always thanks for
watching